blac chyna makes a sexy cameo in a
not-safe-for-work
music video thank you the mom of two is
back to work working it for the cameras
in the new music video for rapper
belly's track peel P power of like what
the social media star Dawn's a blonde
wig while dancing around in a fur coat
white undies and a matching bustier and
now fans are speculating that she might
be throwing shade at her ex-fiance Rob
Kardashian she's known for not like
given to the 29 year old model looks
straight to the camera as he raps quote
she took you for everything you let her
do it again and get this Chyna chose
that snippet of the video to share on
Instagram Wednesday in July the reality
star was granted a temporary restraining
order against Rob after he went on a
social media tirade that included him
posting private images of her on
Instagram and Twitter I would like to
first and foremost thank the judge for
granting me this restraining order to
protect me
a source told et at the time that Rob
felt quote hustled by Chyna who is the
mother of his nine-month-old daughter
dreams meanwhile she isn't shying away
from the limelight just a few weeks ago
she was spotted at an event along with
Tyga the father of her first child and
she dished on how she's doing these days
I'm doing good I'm doing good I'm just
feeling blessed right now
[Music]